now let's imagine that this program
needed an object that bears a
resemblance to this gold one that we
already made to achieve this perhaps we
could start by building a new object and
giving it all the same values stored at
all the same keys we'll make a new
object called blue and we will start
making it look exactly like the gold
object by copying the properties over
one at a time
incidentally there are helper functions
out there that can help you copy all of
the properties from one object onto
another it doesn't come with a language
but you could imagine doing the exact
same thing with a simple for loop this
arrow represents the process of copying
over each of the properties from the
gold object to the blue object now
although the effect of this copy
operation on the blue object will last
indefinitely it's important to remember
that the copying happens just at one
moment during the program's execution it
is not an ongoing copying back and forth
behavior that keeps the two objects in
sync in this case there's only one
property in our gold object so the
copying process is quite simple the
copying process is now complete and
won't be repeated so if our program
later goes on to modify gold or blue
we'd probably only expect them to have
the a property in common after those
modifications